defund the police as a as a widespread  slogan  which by the way  almost no one on the left supports i  mean quite literally almost no one you  you do polling most of the left wants to  reform the police they don't want to  defund it  that's what you're blaming it on and  what about all the mass shootings that  have taken place before that became a  slogan now i tweeted something similar  how do they explain it i tweeted quote  it would be interesting to figure out  why a country like italy for example has  essentially no mass shootings they have  economic problems they have diversity  you know sometimes the right lives to  say well  homogenous countries have less violence  like countries like you know they often  point to norway or whatever  italy is a diverse country uh  what but they have almost no mass  shootings what could be the reason and  the great betsy brant who played marie  on breaking bad responded no one knows  of course tongue-in-cheek  the guns are the difference